Traductor: Elisa Santos
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Un día, en 1965,
cuando manejaba hacia Acapulco
de vacaciones con su familia,
el periodista colombiano
Gabriel García Márquez,
abruptamente dio media
vuelta con su coche,
pidió a su mujer que cuidara las finanzas
de la familia los próximos meses,
y volvió a casa.
El comienzo de un nuevo libro
vino a él súbitamente:
"Muchos años después,
frente al pelotón de fusilamiento,
el coronel Aureliano Buendía
había de recordar aquella tarde remota
en que su padre lo llevó
a conocer el hielo".
En los 18 meses siguientes,
aquellas palabras hicieron florecer
"Cien años de soledad",
una novela que llevaría
la literatura latinoamericana
a la vanguardia del imaginario popular,
y que le valdría a García Márquez
el Premio Nobel de Literatura de 1982.
¿Qué hace esta novela tan extraordinaria?
La novela cuenta
las fortunas e infortunios
de siete generaciones
de la familia Buendía.
Con su prosa elaborada y detallista,
su gran variedad de personajes,
y su narrativa enmarañada,
"Cien años de soledad"
no es un libro fácil de leer.
Pero es muy gratificante,
con una variedad épica
de romances intensos,
guerras civiles,
intrigas políticas,
aventureros trotamundos
y más personajes llamados Aureliano
de los que te puedas imaginar.
Pero no es un mero drama histórico.
"Cien años de soledad"
es uno de los ejemplos más famosos
del género literario conocido
como realismo mágico.
En él, los hechos y poderes sobrenaturales
se describen con un tono
realista y objetivo,
mientras los hechos reales
de la vida y la historia humana
se revelan llenos de absurdos fantásticos.
Los fenómenos surrealistas que ocurren
en el pueblo ficticio de Macondo
se mezclan con los hechos que ocurren
en el país real de Colombia.
Todo empieza con un estado
mítico de aislamiento,
que es gradualmente expuesto
al mundo externo,
y pasa por múltiples calamidades.
Con el pasar de los años,
los personajes envejecen y mueren,
y vuelven como fantasmas,
o reencarnados en la siguiente generación.
Cuando llega a la ciudad
una empresa de frutas estadounidense,
llega también un mecánico romántico,
siempre rodeado de mariposas amarillas.
Una joven mujer empieza a flotar.
Si bien la novela evoluciona
a través de generaciones,
el tiempo pasa de forma cíclica.
Muchos personajes tienen nombres
y características de sus antepasados,
cuyos errores ellos siempre repiten.
Extrañas profecías
y visitas de gitanos misteriosos
dan lugar a batallas y fusilamientos
de repetidas guerras civiles.
La empresa de frutas abre
una plantación cerca del pueblo
y termina masacrando miles
de trabajadores en huelga,
en alusión a la verdadera
"Masacre de las bananeras", de 1928.
Combinado con el realismo
mágico de la novela,
esto produce una percepción de
la historia como una espiral descendente
de la cual los personajes
no consiguen escapar.
Abajo de esta magia, se presenta
el modelo histórico colombiano
y latinoamericano desde
la era colonial en adelante.
Esta es una historia
que el autor conoce bien.
García Márquez creció en una Colombia
dividida por los conflictos civiles
entre los partidos liberal y conservador.
Él también vivió en el México autocrático
e hizo la cobertura periodística
del golpe de estado venezolano de 1958.
Pero tal vez sus abuelos maternos
hayan sido sus mayores influencias.
Nicolás Ricardo Márquez fue un veterano
condecorado de la Guerra de los Mil Días,
cuyos relatos de la revuelta contra
el gobierno conservador colombiano
inclinaron a Gabriel García Márquez
para el lado socialista.
En tanto, la superstición omnipresente
de Doña Tranquilina Iguarán Cotes
se tornó la base del estilo
de “Cien años de soledad”.
La pequeña casa
de los abuelos, en Aracataca,
donde el autor pasó su infancia,
fue su mayor inspiración para Macondo.
Con “Cien años de soledad”,
Gabriel García Márquez
encontró una forma única
de capturar la singular historia
de América Latina.
Fue capaz de retratar la extraña
realidad de una sociedad poscolonial,
forzada a revivir
las tragedias del pasado.
A pesar de todas las fatalidades,
la novela todavía trae esperanza.
En el discurso del Nobel,
García Márquez retrató
la larga historia latinoamericana,
marcada por conflictos civiles
y grandes desigualdades.
Pero terminó el discurso afirmando
que era posible construir un mundo mejor:
"Donde nadie pueda decidir
por otros hasta la forma de morir,
donde de veras sea cierto el amor
y sea posible la felicidad,
y donde las estirpes condenadas
a cien años de soledad
tengan por fin y para siempre una segunda
oportunidad sobre la Tierra".